c'est rené clément 61 chez joie des lib
l'équipe d'antonio dirigeante de
visconti le guépard en 60 ans jack
cardiff a mis la moto s'est fait très
bon film personne de louis malle
sur plein donc de l'osé en complète
c'était en 76 godard aussi godard avec
nouvelle vague en soit 790
verture avec le retour de casanova en
[Musique]
et plusieurs projection à cannes classic
alors que les officiels du festival
applaudissent au monsieur alain delon de
l'église de mélodie en sous-sol
les ministres de la culture franck
riester qui accueille à l'indolence ion
premier le maire de cannes présidé par
le président du festival pierre lescure
[Musique]
le délégué général qui fait a dit rester
défraiements alain delon et frédérick
roy doit elle aussi fait la bise et à
frédéric dans la présidence du cese
c'est un monsieur de langues
on
alain delon aux côtés de franck cester
le ministre de la culture
venu sur les marches accueillir
monument du cinéma français
du cinéma mondial
[Musique]
et
alain delon qui eux
sur sa veste à accrocher un pin's avec
la couverture de paris match
à l'hôpital
c'est en 1991 à la naissance de sa fille
avec la mère de sa fille et sa fille
bébé
sa fille anouchka que l'on doit avec lui
aux démarches
ils vont rentrer dans le palais du
festival
une dernière photo en haut des marches
musique d'une cordée
s'il ya un
d'ennio morricone
et voilà donc alain delon qu'il allait
retourner sur une dernière fois
fouda très très heureux ce soir et de
lino ventura ses amis malgré le temps le
temps qu'on garde très moyen
[Musique]
maire de cannes d'un ministère
la présidente du cnc frédérique bredin
maison de la culture manchester le
président et le tgb général du festival
les frères bon
et toujours
[Musique]